cette attaque de vendredi on vous l'a
dit elle est revendiquée par des
terroristes liés à al qaeda au maghreb
islamique qu'on appelle la cnhi il avait
occupé le nord du mali il y a trois ans
mais il avait été durement frappés et
affaibli par les forces françaises
depuis on en avait plus beaucoup entendu
parler sophie alors est ce que ça
signifie un retour en force d'aqmi dans
cette région oui et non oui parce que
cela voudrait dire 4me aurait décidé de
modifier sa stratégie de cibler
maintenant davantage les étrangers c'est
à dire que les occidentaux étaient
jusqu'ici surtout les victimes de prises
d'otages mais avec l' attaque contre
leur addition à bamako au mali en
novembre et l'attaquent du splendid à
ouagadougou vendredi
il semblerait selon des agents du
service français qu'aqmi devrait
maintenant faire plus d'actes d'éclat en
ciblant des intérêts occidentaux
peut-être des minières pas juste des
hôtels où se tiennent les occidentaux et
non parce que nous on a l'impression
qu'ils étaient un peu en retrait depuis
quelques années mais ils n'ont jamais
cessé d'attaquer de prendre en otage de
faire des attentats
ils avaient été repoussés par les forces
françaises dans les montagnes du désert
mais les attend il n'y a pas une semaine
qui passe sans qu'il y ait un attentat
ou une attaque soit au mali ou au niger
on peut regarder si vous voulez une
cassure montre l'étendue du phénomène
alors la zone d'influencé d'aqmi en 2010
donc avant les révoltes du printemps
arabe et la chute de kadhafi se limitait
à l'est de la mauritanie le mali le
niger le tchad depuis ça s'est étendu
malgré la présence des forces françaises
et onusiennes au mali jusqu'au sénégal
dans le sens où il n'y a pas encore eu
d'attentât au sénégal il ya eu une
trentaine d'imams et de prêcheur qui ont
été arrêtées là en novembre
certains sont accusés d'avoir voulu
comploter et d'avoir financé des
attentats donc maintenant aussi le
burkina faso le tchad ou le niger le
mali il ya aussi bien sûr
boko haram au nigeria pas seulement
achmea ça c'est mon ami
alors il ya beaucoup ahram le nord du
nigeria maintenant aussi au tchad au
cameroun au nord du cameroun et au sud
du niger on voit des zones où les deux
groupes civis au point où
le gouvernement nigérien a déplacé
aujourd'hui une centaine d'écoles de
cette région
plus au nord pour que les élèves
puissent être mis hors de portée de la
violence de boko haram
il y a aussi dans l'est du continent un
autre groupe d al shabab qui sévissent
et qui sont basés en somalie et qui
était à l'origine affiliés à al qaïda
mais qui commence tranquillement à
prêter allégeance à l'état islamique de
comme beaucoup en ram d'ailleurs et qui
font des actes at depuis quelques années
aux kenyans et qui commence à cibler
aussi l'ouganda la capitale donc
peut-être éventuellement là aussi contre
des étrangers
et pourtant vous le disais donc des
troupes françaises des troupes de l'onu
se bat contre 6 groupes jihadistes les
américains aussi les aides et pourtant
il ya des attentats alors on peut se
demander qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
contre s'il vous plaît il faut faire
plus c'est clair ces gouvernements leur
sont pauvres ils n'ont pas les moyens de
se défendre de prévoir des attentes
encore moins de se défendre on l'a vu
vendredi à ouagadougou un gendarme
aujourd'hui disait qu'il n'avait même
pas l'équipement pour voir dans la nuit
pour défoncer des portes ne vais même
pas de boucliers ont dû attendre
l'arrivée des forces spéciales
françaises pour faire l'assaut contre le
splendide donc il faut faire plus
techniquement pour les aider mais ce que
tout le monde qui connaît la région dit
c'est pour éviter que ces jeunes aient
envie d'aller se battre et se faire tuer
il faut les éduquer et s'assurer qu'ils
à une emploi en sortant de l'école
la solution n'est pas que militaire
merci beaucoup ceci je vous en plus
et si vous voulez en savoir davantage
sur cet attentat de ouagadougou vous
pouvez consulter notre dossier web vous
voyez l'adresse à l'écran